thank you very much and thank you
everyone for coming along today the last
kind of Real Talk of the conference what
an amazing turnout uh so my name is John
um if you want to tweet at me throughout
this talk uh then it's just John
underscore sandal on Twitter uh so I am
CEO of coefficient coefficient we're a
data consultancy uh you'll find out more
about what we do because I'm gonna tell
you about the kind of stuff that we do
for our clients so
I'm gonna walk you through an
introduction to the modern data stack uh
more importantly the python powered
modern day stack I'm a pythonista and
I'm going to do that by introducing you
to my fictitious company megacorp who
sells software so welcome to megacorp
imagine you are just starting a role as
head of data at Mega Corp and you're
being welcome to the team you've got a
lovely looking office there and we're
going to introduce you to some
characters to help illustrate our
journey today so first of all let's meet
on our day one the CTO of megacorp and
the C2 says we've got some Data Systems
we've got SQL Server that's our main
product database we've got some products
from customers some orders there's a
financial system that has all of the
main sort of Legally uh stuff in there
the bank accounts the transactions we
also do lots of analysis and Excel
different teams do their own thing uh
we've got some dashboards as well
they're actually just Excel but we call
them dashboards there's some other
systems around but we don't really use
them for analytics something the
developers do
some of you might be feeling seen and
heard at this point let's meet our
software Engineers uh the awesome
pythonista in the room comes to all the
pie datas and the picons knows their
stuff so what are they doing well they
decided they wanted a better analytics
data warehouse so they wrote some ETL
pipelines using python they've got
pandas SQL Alchemy to take stuff out of
various different Upstream data sources
load them into bigquery they've got a
really nice ETL pipeline being
orchestrated by open source tool Apache
airflow they've got a really good
testing they're using all of the best
practices all the things that you're
learning about and in the other talks of
this conference they've got some
scheduling some of it's with airflow but
some of it is just stuff they do every
Monday morning at 9am manually they just
run it on the laptop and maybe there's
some bits and pieces that run using cron
but by and large they're trying to
implement software engineering best
practices to their data pipelines so
they're probably they're applying dry
programming principles don't repeat
yourself where that stuff is happening
in the SQL Server layer they're using
store procedures they're using views and
the other thing we've got here is there
is a product analytics platform I'm not
going to name it says loads of them out
there I've just made one app called
events logger it logs events that's what
it does there's loads of tools that do
this kind of thing
so what's the kind of best practices
that you may be aware of and if you're
not aware of them really cool tools that
I'm going to tell you about so data
validation within your pipeline again
this is reasonably good best practice so
there's a really lovely tool called
pandira there's also things like Great
Expectations that do a similar thing and
it allows you to create a schema if
you're a Django developer maybe you
don't even need this because you're
managing all of this in your Django
layer if you're not gotjango in the mix
then I really love the combination of
SQL Alchemy and Pandera it's a little
bit like pedantic plus plus for data
pipeline validation so you can specify
your schema you can then run a data
frame in pandas in memory through your
schema and make sure that it validates
on the types correct that you don't have
a sort of string Fields coming into your
date times and you can also even
validate whether they've got nulls in
them if they're not meant to have if
they're an integer that they're unique
or that they're between a certain value
range or if they're categorical data
type again that they meet things that
you've seen before and you don't have
someone again maybe in the marketing
team suddenly throwing in New Field
categories that maybe you need to map in
this is very common in the product
analytics pipelines people like to
create just new events and maybe you
need to merge them into Old events
because someone's changed their casing
other people don't care about us casing
as much as us pythonisters
so we can validate our data within our
pandas layer and and
panda is a wonderful tool for doing that
what else is our software engineer doing
they're doing other little bits and
pieces that require python in the mix
this can't all just be done in SQL so
here's a nice little example of maybe
they're doing some lookups via an API
they need to map all of their
transactions from pounds and euros and
other currencies into dollars so they
can be quickly analyzed in one query in
their data warehouse so maybe they're
using apis to do this but maybe they
just this is one of their Monday morning
jobs they've got to do shows of us using
Apache airflow but they've got so many
other things to do at the moment and
this kind of just works as long as they
don't go on holiday it kind of just
works
so let's see what else is happening in
megacorp we've got the head of sales and
the data scientists doing some cool
stuff together so let's see what's going
on in the sales World we've got a lead
generation agency that they're
purchasing leads from uh to Salva
software too and every Monday at 9am the
lead generation agency uploads some CSV
or maybe it's an Excel file into an FTP
bucket so more data coming into the
organization this is really really
useful valuable data because it's what's
powering the entire commercial operation
of megacorp but there's a manual process
around it they they take it out of the
FTP bucket as an Excel file they load it
into their CRM tool and they actually
spoke to their awesome data scientist
who thought I can automate this a little
bit for you so they use Python and
pandas they even use a bit of
scikit-learn on the side to build a lead
scoring algorithm so they can Target the
most effective leads first but to be
honest she's not really sure how to
evaluate that she's evaluating it based
on people they've spoken to in the past
they don't actually have the downstream
data in their their CRM tool or anywhere
else easily accessible that's joined up
across all the different systems so they
might be speaking to a lead from one
organization but maybe someone else in
the organization with a slightly
different email is signing up to the
tool they don't really tying of this
together and also there seems to be
wowing everyone at the organization wow
we've got Ai and our lead scoring very
cool
so this is this is also working
operational she just again it only comes
in every Monday at 9am so she just runs
this script every Monday at 10 A.M and
it pops using a nice uh API python
client that generic CRM has she can just
load that data straight into that tool
so the sales team can quickly create
their own automated Target list
still got some cool stuff happening in
sales in engineering what about Finance
what are they up to so in the world of
Finance we've got SQL Server that's your
core database kind of that has to be
accurate the amount of Revenue that's
tracked there should really match the
amount of Revenue it's tracked in their
generic accounting system but the head
of Finance maybe they have their own
analysts because Normal data analyst
they don't sound Finance there's all
sorts of things and weird words like
journals and uh and and revenue that
people don't really understand sometimes
especially when you start talking about
tax and gross and net so they have their
own analysts they have their own manual
processes it's all Excel based it works
don't come and mess with the financial
systems they're too valuable to disrupt
but hey uh we've got lots of manual
reconciliation and things mostly match
uh within our level of materiality as
long as it's within you know ten
thousand dollars or so we don't really
care if there's a slight error you know
as Finance
so then maybe it's day two I've I've had
my introductions and I speak to the CEO
and the CEO is saying
how can we improve there's I get this
feeling that we're probably working in
sort of Circa 2018 style data
infrastructure what is 2023 hold for us
and so I walk the CEO through I say
you've got some really good skills in
the team you've got data Engineers
you've got python clean tested code your
data is being validated at least in one
tiny part of your pipeline where you've
got a bigquery data analytics system uh
you've got Cloud scheduling at least for
some of your setup you've got machine
learning optimization within your sales
process you're using Python and pandas
really effectively to do what they're
good at
what could be improved well at the
moment you're kind of struggling with
your your your your uh data engineer is
actually just getting larger and larger
and larger uh Cloud servers to process
their memory because hey why not just
have a two terabyte Ram system on on
your uh bigquery uh or or on your Google
Cloud platform because it's kind of
cheap especially if you're just using it
a few times a week but really this is
not going to scale very well especially
if you really start flying and you've
got terabytes of information flowing
through your pipelines so what is out
there to help you move out of in-memory
ETL jobs you've also got a lot of tech
debt there's a lot of code maintenance
you've got a small team you've got one
data scientists and a few software
engineers and they've got a lot of
things to do let alone helping the rest
of the business figure out what they can
be doing to advance themselves
especially when some of the rest of the
business doesn't really want to advance
what they're doing in terms of data
maturity
so you've got lots of organizational
silos you've got analysts and different
teams some of them are going a bit Rogue
you've got a data warehouse they're not
even using it they're just writing SQL
queries directly against your database
and they're bringing in all sorts of bad
data they're bringing all of your
testing QA teams data because they don't
know what to filter out so you've also
as a result got lots of different
dashboards showing different numbers and
when you say how much revenue do we make
this month if you ask three different
people getting three different answers
again is anybody feeling seen this is
something I've seen quite a few times
for our clients
so what am I going to do I'm going to
map out their systems at least let's
start figuring out where the problems
are we've got leads we've got the core
database product platform we've got
events which is sort of going somewhere
not even being looked at by the product
team we've got financial data we've got
manual reports we've got a data
warehouse we've got a CRM
some of these are kind of siled and the
SQL Server does a little bit of talking
to the serum it tries to tell it when
someone's signed up for an account so
the sales team can reconcile and not uh
sell to people who are already customers
but it's a little bit uh Rough and Ready
so what does better look like
introducing the modern data sack so
first of all moving into the theory part
of my presentation let's talk about ETL
elt ETL TL and a few other technical
jargon that I found an absolute
Minefield when just trying to understand
what the modern data stack is because
it's a very buzzwordy seller stuff so
let's keep it simple ETL some of you'll
be quite familiar with this you extract
data from some system you transform it
probably a memory using Python and
pandas you load it into some other
system so ephemeral in memory that's a
transform layer that's the stuff that
you do day in and day out and then you
load it into wherever it's going to live
as a persistent storage
then we heard people talking a lot about
elt this sort of Paradigm Shift where
instead of doing your transformation
layer in memory using python or pandas
you actually extract your data from
Source you load it into your data Lake
something like databricks or your data
warehouse something like snowflake or
bigquery uh this was covered very nicely
the other day by I think Florian in the
world stack presentation uh data Lake
being basically throw your data into it
and it's kind of raw but we can start
doing joins on top of on top of that and
the data Lake like databricks is moving
kind of in the direction of data
warehouse where you can do
transformations in that layer too if
you've used things like Hive as well
with Hadoop similar sort of concept we
we just throw stuff into it and then we
start trying to join it together your
data warehouse is something where again
you can load stuff into it in a little
bit more of a structured format and you
do your transformations in that layer as
well so typically your data Lakey
Warehouse or data lake houses or
whatever they're going to call them next
year these are your load transform
single storage unit you put data in
there you transform it using things like
SQL views materialize tables udfs again
we're getting into jargon so let's cover
that jargon
SQL views this is a virtualized table
it's created by a query it's not kind of
real it's there it's read-only uh you
can't change it it's a bit like a
hologram a materialized table this is
creating that physical copy of the
result set of your query so you can
quickly turn a view into a materialize
table in many tools these days just by
adding a config flag such as materialize
and these can be updated periodically or
on demands the upside of these is your
Downstream query is going to be faster
if you materialize your tables the
downsize is going to require more
storage space and also who's updating it
and is that process running or or is it
something that someone has to run
manually or is it potentially falling
over who's going to get an alert if that
falls over this gets very complex very
fast which is why people kind of like
the SQL views because they just run in
that moment and then we also hear about
things like udfs the user-defined
functions think of it as just a function
but these are written usually in things
like SQL or JavaScript depending on your
platform so if it's bigquery then that
has JavaScript udfs snowflake people
like talking about it because and here
because they also support python Java
and Scala in their udfs so here's a
little example of a snowflake python
user defined function it's defined in
the runtime version it Imports some
packages there's a little bit of xgbs
going on there this isn't doing much
useful stuff it's just printing out some
packaged versions just to show that it
can
but these are the sort of things that
you get in your data warehousie tool
layers
so back to what we're talking about elt
lots of things we can do in that layer
but the modern data stack I like to
think of as slightly different because
there's an extra TL in there so
extractor load to transform using your
transformation tool of choice it could
be python but I'm going to be talking to
you about DBT today and then we load it
into its final resting place at the end
of the day so we start thinking about a
raw data leaky Dumping Ground try and
keep it relatively clean otherwise it
becomes a data swamp I've had it called
and then we actually cleaned it up we
transform we take just what we need we
do our typecasting and our other
Transformations and then we load it into
a really clean documented analytics
Warehouse
so here's your typical modern data stack
we've got a various Upstream sources we
use extraction tools open source or SAS
we load them into a raw data Lake we do
some transformation we generate a clean
data warehouse we then do cool stuff
with it reporting or data mining or even
reverse ETL there's some of those little
data bits that are really useful to have
in those Upstream operational data
sources so here's how this might look
for Mega Corp we've got our various data
sources on the left we use some
extraction tools the relevant tool for
you is going to be completely dependent
on your needs depending on your level of
technical maturity and your level of
funding but there are open source tools
there are commercial tools that have
different features and price points
and then there are tools that we could
use for reporting again open source
light Dash metabase both DBT aware
there's also the usual go-to commercial
providers you've got your data mining
tools which you talk about every day at
Pi datas and you've got your reverse
etls there isn't much open source in the
world of reverse ETL so if you're
thinking about your next open source
project maybe consider that space
because the paid for platforms are very
good and very expensive we're talking
about sort of thousand dollar a month
base pricing for some of these although
what do we use internally coefficient we
use make because it's like 10 000
operations for ten dollars a month I am
literally like my time is more expensive
than ten dollars a month I'm just going
to go for the thing that serves my needs
for cheap so give that a go it's
previously integromat and they've just
rebranded and slashed their prices
so this is the sort of process we might
be talking about
and it's a lot better I think than this
process because stuff is beginning to
talk to each other we can integrate
across all of these different systems
across the CRM across the financial
system make sure they're talking uh to
each other and that if we've got
valuable information on our warehouse
that can be fed back into those Upstream
systems so finally Showtime what does
this look like in practice first of all
our head of sales we want to automate
extraction from our CRM system into
bigquery I'm going to use the open
source tool air byte if you don't want
to orchestrate this yourself then you
can pay them some amount of money but to
be honest if you know Docker you can
just run air by it yourself and deploy
that to using your favorite Cloud
platform so I can find my favorite CRM
tool I can see what it's got available
for me I can run this locally on my
machine it's just a Docker thing and I
can then go into that Docker Docker race
thing once it runs it gives me a web UI
it's very beautiful for a piece of Open
Source software and I can set it up and
what will that look like once it all
gets integrated it looks like this this
is is my Google bigquery Warehouse it's
got literally everything in my CRM has
been neatly packaged and presented into
small raw staging tables that I can then
see how they link together and so on
um just to be honest uh this is actually
using five chances five channels cost me
about five dollars a month but it's a
very similar output to what airbite
would give you
so I can see all of my tables I can see
some of the information in those tables
my entire CRM instantly and perpetually
synced into my data warehouse for about
five minutes of my time at five dollars
a month or even free if you can do some
docker deployments
what about the lead generation again
we've got FTP uh connectors uh within
air by other open source tools worth
mentioning meltano singer bonobo you can
run these and orchestrate them yourself
or you can pay Montana a little bit of
money to do it on their Cloud uh what
can we do with my my zero for the
finance team so again
um the the financial extractors they do
exist in the open source side so we've
got a we've got meltanos zero extractor
as we'll see there is a full-on GitHub
repo for this each individual extractor
so if it's not working for something
breaks because xero broke their API then
you can open a ticket and go fix it
yourself it's just connecting to API and
the the core software is handling all of
the Upstream Transformations and
extractions so when something changes in
my Upstream accounts then that
immediately gets synced into my
Downstream database
right next up DDT so we've got loads of
raw data
in our staging data warehouse how do we
then do that Transformations so you'll
be used to using python to do this but
DBC is a very nice open source Tool uh
we can hook it up to our data warehouse
using our profile so this is a very
quick uh sort of three minute DBT 101
and this has been one of the greatest
things that I've learned about and
really learned myself in the last 12
months or so so very excited to show it
to you because maybe it's useful for you
as well so we point it this in this case
to my my bigquery warehouse
and then let's have a look at my DBT
project file so we can see there's loads
of conflicts it's a bit like a pine
project.yaml we can also see that
there's going to be the the downstream
warehouse and models are going to be all
set up here and I'm even saying for my
zero tables I want you to materialize
their output as views
at least as a as a default you can
change this on a table by table layer
but that's my default so let's go and
have a look at my xero models how's that
going to look so my xero models have a
zero schema and uh this schema basically
just defines what tables are going to be
used there's like 300 tables in there I
don't need them all to solve a simple
problem uh for my finance director such
as are you underpaying or overpaying
your vat uh or your tax this year
so we choose the tables that I want to
use and then for each of these tables
I'm going to create a a mini extraction
layer this is all about applying
software engineering best practices into
your data warehouse pipelines you can do
this using SQL you can also use Python
for this if you wish
and then what I'm going to be able to do
is from those clean staging tables I'm
going to be able to bring them together
into a single
Downstream analytics table which brings
them and applies all the joins and the
mergers
how does that look once I'm done then I
can see I can run DBT run
deep sea run is going to power all of
those tables into my Downstream data
analytics Warehouse
it's going to then materialize some of
them because some of them I only need as
views in the moment they just get used
as staging posts to keep everything
really clean and separated trying to
apply dry programming principles so that
any piece of type casting is done once
and once only as early as possible any
other transformation layers like
converting Pence into pounds or dates
into UTC for example again only happens
once into the staging layer and then
it's done by the time I bring it into my
little vat analytics table which
actually solves the problem for the
finance team
other nice features of DBT it's got
testing built directly into it so you
can specify in your DBT schema you can
say I would like you to check the
following columns are unique that this
one has not got nulls in it that these
uh are unique together there's a
relationship between this one and this
one that it meets these uh pandora-like
data quality validation checks and just
like using pi test we can run DBT tests
in our CI layer and it's done for us
and then finally a really nice thing I
like about DBT is that if you add
descriptions in your yaml files it's
going to generate some documentation for
you so if you're working in an
organization where nobody's really
talking to each other and half the
problem is because nobody knows what's
in the data warehouse or what these
column names is or when you say net
revenue is that really net revenue is it
gross revenue and can we do some data
lineage tracking to figure out what this
Revenue number actually means and where
it came from and there are really good
tools that plug into DBT that will do
that for you where did this column come
from in my bi tool you can trace it all
the way back and see that actually uh
that's not very mean that's gross
revenue go and talk to the finance
analyst and make sure that's correct so
this is your generated DBT documentation
project beautiful HTML website
we can also do machine learning we can
do python it doesn't have to be SQL only
so this is dbc's latest 2022 update some
very cool things you can also
materialize tables as incremental so it
can watch an upstream table see if
there's new rows and then just load in
the new rows into your Downstream tables
so finally to wrap up the future the ca
is going to say to me what skills do we
need
in our team is it data visualization is
it Engineers is it analysts is it
envelops is it devops what is it that we
need and the modern data stack answer is
this new role the analytics engineer and
to be honest I'm still fighting off
people saying that data science isn't a
real thing uh even in 2023 I'm sure some
of you have experienced that too
analytics Engineers are going to have a
rough time for next decade I do think
that there's something in this so they
are someone who sits in between your
technical team and your business team
they're much closer to the business
problems the kind of stuff that the
finance team is saying you know what we
just got our own analysts they
understand what we need they're going to
do this thing for us and are less
encumbered by the problems of
orchestration and so on
now there is a relationship to the uh
the future of work here we've not only
got new roles appearing in Tech and data
we've got new roles appearing in the
business side uh we just completed last
year a online course for the chartered
Institute of Taxation in the UK this
course was uh creating an online diploma
for tax technologists and I think we're
going to see this across every major
industry you're going to have legal
people who are being told your job's
going to get automated they're not going
to get automated they're just going to
learn new skills they're going to get
more techie they're going to understand
everything that we're talking about
today because I've just written an
entire diploma that teaches tax and
accountants how to do this so this is
the exciting New World where we can show
a slide like this to a load of contents
which is first of all relevant to you
but it's also relevant to them because
they're the ones that are going to have
to start making these decisions or
talking to the rest of the the ctOS and
their team who are going to be helping
them to orchestrate the tools they need
to do their job so this is a slide from
that used with permission from the ciot
but also a very relevant slide to my
talk today because it shows you that in
every single stage of the modern data
stat there are open source under a SAS
tools what's relevant for you is going
to be dependent on do you know Docker if
you don't know how to Docker is
something else chat GPT I'm sure it will
help you because if you can you can
really use those open source tools
so to wrap up with the CEO they're going
to say how does that help me it's going
to save you time and money for your
organization okay there's reduced cost
and time to get up and running you can
sync an entire Upstream data source into
a load of nice clean relational tables
in your data staging warehouse and you
can do that in about five minutes this
is much faster than the months it used
to take me back in 2015 for example
doing this using python alone and really
struggling through the API documentation
of some option data source the speed of
processing if you're using some of these
tools you can process stuff at scale
this is what DBT and Python and
Snowflake and all these other Big Data
Warehouse are designed to do terabyte
byte scale data processing using the
same stack that works locally on your
machine as well the licensing commercial
open source clouds hosted up to you go
with the thing that meets your budget
that you can use finally this is going
to give you much better data you can
integrate data from all the different
sources it's scale ready you're going to
get much better data accuracy if you
really want to go crazy into the modern
day sack you can bring in additional
sometimes quite cheap tooling that'll
tell you if you've got some product
analytics pipeline that's fallen over
because some developer forgot to include
that call in your mobile app this month
so you will be able to get alerted and
you can fix these issues rapidly you can
also see if there's there's type or data
quality issues happening the moment they
happen
so I just want to finish off with my
vision of the next stage of data
maturity many of you will be organized
working organizations where data is
probably critical the one in the middle
because you're at a data conference or a
python conference but uh as we move into
Data driven uh you can start moving
towards self-serve analytics some of our
best clients are sort of in the
self-serve analytics space they're able
to answer what happened but anyone in
the organization is able to answer what
happened that last month or which of our
a b tests uh was was the most performant
when we're looking at the downstream
conversion rates not just the things
easy to chat the things that are right
to track but next uh I think I'm looking
forward to using these tools to do more
it's not about just saving time or money
or doing things faster it's about the
opportunity cost of what else can you do
now you've got all this new time on your
hands and everything is just being
handled for you we can do more
predictive modeling we can predict
what's going to happen or we can start
treating our data systems like I teach
uh treat chat gbt which is hey what
should I do in this scenario
um how do I best negotiate with this
contract these are things that AI is
really good for and you can make it
really bespoke for your organizations
give your CEO tools where you can put it
actually figure out what should I do
thank you very much for your time
thank you so much for such a ground
covering talk so many things to ask
questions about
um
we have quite some but we only have a
little bit of time left we might go a
little bit
over because the next thing coming up is
cake and coffee so
um first question for you who will
maintain this whole system of eltl who
is going to be responsible
it's a really good question so at the
moment you probably need a lot of
different skills to work on let alone
maintain one of these systems you need
the python you need the devops you need
to have good understanding of the
command line you need to have good
understandable SQL and you also need to
understand all the nuances of your
Finance teams hacks in the way that they
use their bookkeeping system
what this hopefully reveals is a new way
of working where any one person in an
organization when a large organization
and a small team can handle all the
devops they handle the orchestration
they put the tools out there and more
people especially if you're looking for
your next five ten hires are working at
analytics engineering layer they're
closer to business because all they need
to know is SQL and a bit of python if
you need some data scientists helping
them out with the machine learning side
of things great but it means just a lot
more people who can work at the SQL
python business interface instead of all
the the devops there's less of that and
more of the value drivers
are your slides available somewhere I
will put them up on on GitHub and I will
tweet out on my Twitter so at John
underscore sandal and you can find out
where these slides are going to end up
given our limited time I'll skip the
question if you're a fan of Brooklyn
Nine-Nine or we can maybe cut this short
uh how did you guess okay
is there a modern data science stack a
modern stack for ML Ops
um
what I would love to share my favorite
resource that I've learned in the last
year in terms of like the modern amalek
stack is there's a really good free
online course it's called Full stack
deep learning.com it covers a lot of
these tools it covers things like DVC
and weights and biases and other sort of
machine learning monitoring
observability tooling a lot of it open
source it's completely free you can pay
if you want like mentoring or tutorials
or whatever but it's completely free and
it's really really high quality so
that's fullstack deep learning.com
could you go into the details about a
Pandera versus pedantic
the kind of things you want to be using
say pedantic helps you to specify your
types it's type aware in the the python
typing sense but Pandora has quite a lot
of nice tooling for uh specifically
saying things like this is an age we
shouldn't have 200 year olds in our data
in our data warehouse which having
worked a lot with the UK government
departments over the last year there's a
lot of that there's a lot of very very
very dead people in core critical
systems so if that's you check it out
the actual AI models would also be in
the data warehouse will the data
scientists themselves put them into the
warehouse or how can they check if
everything is fine
good question
um this is kind of what is comfortable
for you to do do you want to deploy your
AI models as just here is a model asset
that is going to be put into S3 you're
using DVC weights and biases these kind
of things and you've got your model
registry in which case you can pull it
from there within your data warehouse
layer within your DBT layer for example
and then you can do your machine
learning there or you could have an API
if that's your thing I think it's really
up to you
okay and with that I think we'll wrap it
up thank you so much again it was really
interesting thank you